In extreme ownership.
You talk about being close with the team,
but not so close that they forget who's in charge or that the good of the team
suffers.
How do you overcome the isolation of leadership?
What strategies did or do you employ to avoid the isolation becoming an issue?
This is an example of,
I'm going to take this to the extreme.
Hey,
I'm not going to be too close to my people.
Guess what?
I'm not talking to them,
right?
I'm not going to speak to them.
I'm going to,
I gotta maintain a distance.
I got up and it's,
it's obviously not true.
It's obviously not true.
And I think,
you know,
the relationship that you and me and Seth and the,
that we all had was clearly,
uh,
this,
right?
I wasn't alone.
I wasn't isolated as the leader because we were all bros and hanging out.
And now did it start off like,
oh no,
you know,
I,
as we always talk about like our come across Hackworth style of like,
Hey,
we're not going to joke around for at least whatever,
six to eight weeks to make sure that these dudes are good to go and that,
that they understand where I'm coming from and,
and that's cool.
But once we get through that,
okay,
like,
then it's like open up a little bit,
then it's like open up a little bit more.
And then as I've grown up a little bit more so that you're not isolated at the
top because not only is it important that you're not isolated,
that's like,
that's like a marginal thing.
What's more important is what I talked about earlier is if you,
if Lafe can't come to me and say,
hey man,
hey,
I don't agree with this plan.
Or more importantly,
Hey Jocko,
here's what's going on with the troops right now.
Here's what's going on with the mentality.
Here's what's going on with the morale.
If he can't knock on my door and say that to me,
then that's a real problem.
Because now,
um,
you know,
in the dark on what's happening inside inside with the troops,
which is problematic.
Yeah.
I think it's,
this to me sounds like a,
I was thinking about this question and it sounds to me like a maybe a junior
leader that was promoted at the shame cause that cause that's where you really
feel like when I go from,
you know,
the assistant platoon commander where I'm like kind of one of the boys and um,
we're,
we can,
you know,
it's kind of a,
I can kind of play interference with it with the officer in charge and the
platoon commander now all of a sudden I get promoted.
You recognize instantly there's a little bit of difference.
You've got to maybe kind of distance yourself slightly from where you were
previously and recognize when you took over.
Yeah.
Charlie Patina as a platoon commander,
when did you realize that you needed to transition from being one of the boys
until being the OIC and that there was,
that the gap was going to open up a little bit?
Was it as soon as you took over?
It was pretty quick because I'd been to buds and,
and a seal qualification training,
you know,
escuchar advanced training with a,
with several guys.
And I knew these guys very well and you know,
I think we had a big house party hanging out,
you know,
having a good time and,
and uh,
everybody's over at my house and all of a sudden I realized some I did all the
time,
you know,
as an assistant platoon commander and all of a sudden,
uh,
we're in at work,
you know,
the next week and I got to get to,
uh,
make some,
some tough calls and we've got to get,
you know,
drive the a little bit higher where we're at.
And there's some pushback and you realize like,
okay,
when it's,
when it's time to give people some bad news or say,
hey,
we're not doing as good as we should.
We need to fix that.
And they kind of give you the leg,
hey bro,
you know,
what are you doing on Friday?
Then it's,
then you're like,
okay,
I'm going to have to,
I'm going to have to distance a little bit.
But he did the isolation.
You should never be isolated.
I think that's one thing that,
you know,
I remember coming into your office and,
uh,
I would come in and hang on all the time and your office,
you know,
you,
you'd come in and hang out in the platoon space.
I mean,
I've come,
you know,
we'd,
we'd see each other in the gym was like,
we were always trying to find a way to like hang out and talk and,
and,
um,
it was even when,
you know,
Seth stone was all the way across the other side of the city.
I mean,
I,
you know,
we'd still connect with them and talk to him on the phone and once,
well,
yeah,
I talked to him all the time on the A and DVT.
Yeah,
you guys do you guys talk.
But having,
but even me,
you know,
we'd always w he came by,
like,
we'd always try to try to get together and talk to each other and catch up,
whether it's in the Chow Hall or are,
uh,
you know,
in a platoon space.
And,
uh,
you know,
guys,
like I've ever,
Tony would come in there,
I'd come in,
I'd walk in and I'd see the wind plan written up on Tacos,
whiteboard and tasking at bruiser or Tony had written down all the things that
we needed to do to win and robotics,
which were pretty harsh.
Yes.
Probably on the level like Ganga Eskom and certainly there's the con Red Planet,
which,
you know,
hey man,
we are as it's mirror.
We are,
we are joking and laughing about it.
That this is the relationship Jocko hat,
you know,
not only with me but with,
with other leaders in the task unit.
And uh,
and I think you have to have that.
I mean,
you've got to have a,
you've got to have a relationship with your people.
You can't think that I can't talk to anyone.
I can't interact with anyone.
And I think this,
you're going to be unsuccessful as a leader.
Um,
you know,
if,
if you try to roll that way,
it's just not gonna work.
Yeah.
I think where you might feel what might feel like a isolation,
which is definitely true.
And this is the burden of command,
right?
Like guess what?
You're friends with Lafe,
you're friends with Seth,
you're friends with Tony,
you're friends with these guys.
But at the same time,
like,
oh,
the burden of command is on you and it's going to be,
it's going to be you.
You're going to,
you're going to bear that,
right in your platoon.
It's like,
Hey,
you got your assistant platoon commanders,
you got your opportunity if you've got your Lpo.
But when something goes wrong,
if something goes wrong,
if you,
if there's a bad,
if something happens on a mission and it goes bad,
I'm not talking,
I'm not,
I'm not looking at the assistant platoon commander.
I'm,
I'm looking at you.
That's the burden of command.
That's so that thing.
Yeah,
that's,
that there's one man that stands on the carpet,
right?
That's,
that's the way it works.
And sometimes being one man,
that's,
that's a little bit of an isolating feeling.
And to help help you understand that our leading petty officer Charlop tune,
awesome,
amazing seal,
but love the guy.
And uh,
hopefully it can be on here one of these days.
But after,
maybe they're heroes as retirement cups when one of these days.
But,
uh,
he was,
I remember we were,
we were up in Nevada training and,
uh,
we took a couple of days to go snowboarding,
which was a,
an awesome,
good deal.
And he's like,
oh,
we're in the van.
He looks around,
he sees me.
He's like,
I'm not the senior guy.
And she,
and uh,
so he's screaming and laughing about how awesome it is to not be the senior guy
cause he knows the burden of command is now with me,
not with him.
If fuck guys get in trouble or do something stupid,
they should have done,
which is,
while you're in Tahoe guys getting in trouble and doing stuff,
stupid is probably a fairly likely thing to happen.
Highly probable.
That's one of my favorite trips that I did multiple times.
Yeah.
So that's it,
man.
Build relationships.
And at the same time you are,
when you're in charge,
you're in charge and there's a little bit of a,
that's called the burden of command.
Embrace it.